voici ilitch ramirez sanchez dit carlos
le terroriste numéro un
il a à son actif un palmarès sans égale
1974 prise d'otages de l'ambassade de la
r15 septembre 74 attentats au drugstore
saint-germain paris de morts 30 blessés
décembre 75 prise d'otage des ministres
de l'opep à vienne après cet attentat il
se réfugie à alger où on le voit sur
cette photo
toujours en 75 à paris deux inspecteurs
de la dst et un de leurs informateurs
sont habitués rue toullier toujours
carlos et puis plus récemment le 29 mars
l'explosion dans le capitole 5 morts et
27 blessés
s'il n'a pas revendiqué cet attentat
carlos avait auparavant adressé à gaston
defferre ministre de l'intérieur un
ultimatum exigeant la libération de deux
terroristes arrêtés à paris le 27 mars
le délai de l'ultimatum est écoulé le 29
mars
c'est l'explosion du capitole autant de
faits et de présomptions qui explique
pourquoi les policiers prennent très au
sérieux
la revendication par l'organisation de
la lutte armée arabe des attentats de la
saint sylvestre organisation d'ailleurs
dont faisait partie carlos mais c'est
l'organisation qui a revendiqué ces
attentats pas carlos lui même
alors peut-on attribuer ces attentats au
terroriste numéro un
ou est ce une part ternie tu es un peu
forcé